So, the Epstein files are out and a lot
of familiar faces are showing up in
there. Trump, Bill Gates, Michael
Jackson, Bill Clinton, all those guys.
And while many of us are happy that the
truth is finally coming out with the
Nickelodeon scandals and the Diddy Files
and the Epstein files, the reason why
all this is happening right now is
pretty terrifying. 2 Thessalonians 2:3
tells us, "Let no man deceive you by any
means, for that day, the coming of the
Lord, shall not come except there come a
falling away first." We are definitely
in a falling away of many sorts. And
Ephesians 6:12 says, "We do not wrestle
against flesh and blood, but against
principalities, against the powers,
against the rulers of the darkness of
this world, Satan is the ruler of this
world who's about to deceive the entire
world." In 1 Timothy 4:1 and2 says, "Now
the spirit expressly says that in the
latter times, which I believe we're
living in now, some will depart from the
faith, giving heed to deceiving spirits
and doctrines of demons." What is about
to happen? That Christians are going to
depart from their faith because of some
supernatural deception that they just
saw. So something supernatural is about
to happen with lying signs, wonders,
miracles, and it's about to deceive the
entire world. Even those who were in the
faith are going to depart because of
these seductive demons. Satan's not
going to appear as a monster. He's going
to appear as an angel of light. He's
going to appear as Christ. And he's not
going to come at a time of peace and
unity. He's coming at a time when
nations are fractured. Trust in
institutions is shattered. Morality is
confused. People are emotionally
exhausted. Justice systems appear
corrupt or broken. And the public is
desperate for order, peace, and rescue.
Are we living in a time where every day
we're just exhausted at how sick and
miserable this world is? Absolutely.
This is about divide and conquer. The
system is dividing us red and blue, left
and right, and order out of chaos. They
have been manufacturing this chaos and
exposing it right now to collapse the
whole structure so that we will be on
our knees desperate crying out for a
savior. And who's going to show up? None
other than Satan appearing as Christ, a
cosmic savior, an angel of light doing
lying signs and wonders. And millions
are going to be deceived and depart from
the faith, giving heed to these seducing
spirits and doctrines of demons. So
remember, the only way we're not going
to be deceived by what is soon to come
on this earth is to be grounded in the
word of God. To be claiming his
promises, to be quoting scripture and
fighting in this supernatural spiritual
warfare by putting on the full armor of
God and fighting Satan with the sword of
the spirit. We have to understand
prophetic events that Satan is coming
before Christ comes. that he's not going
to come out as a monster, but he's going
to come as an angel of light promising
peace and safety and doing lying signs,
wonders, and miracles. We cannot even
trust our senses. We can't just believe
lying signs and wonders. We have to
believe what the word of God says. So
stay awake. Be prepared. Satan's coming
first, but Christ [music] is coming
soon. Are you ready?